La Tempo and he's and he's thinking too
long two seconds one second three he's
gone
did he did he fly did he flag it's not
clear it's hard for me to tell and the
arbitrary is about to intervene yes this
was a game lost by Gary on the clock or
likely to end in a draw how is nepo
doing because nepo was also still uh
let's say he's still playing just to
make sure
it's expected
oh my goodness Gary lost on time no mvl
wins the game
scenes right there we've seen vishy show
some nerves what happened uh oh what
happened three seconds two seconds one
second gone it's over that's it he
flagged what was that I don't know what
it was the game is over guys yeah the
game is over Gary what was that